When you think about ways to describe yourself, Lauren, what do you think about?
>> Well, there's physical traits, like, you know, height or body shape, and
then, well, there's personality traits like extroversion
or introversion, and then there's my interests,
so like music or art. So there are many features we could use
to describe an individual, and we call
these traits. Traits are any distinguishing feature
of an individual. For example, Lauren, if you had
to describe yourself in three traits, what would you say?
>> well, I have light hair. I'm outgoing. And I'm really into psychology.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I think I would say that I'm tall, I'm pretty friendly,
outgoing as well, and I'm a huge lover of the Zelda series of video
games from Nintendo.
>> So, are you saying that all of our traits
come from our genome? Well to a certain extent we're
saying that all of these attributes are traits, but the
extent to which they're influenced by our genome is variable.
>> Okay, because I was going to say, things like
my personal interests I don't think come from the genome.
>> Sure. I mean things like height are, are
things that we suspect would have a major genetic component.
whereas my general love of video games, probably
has less to do with my genetics, and a
lot more to do with my environment. For our
purposes in this course, we'll use three main categorizations
for traits. We'll have physical vs. behavioral traits,
visible vs. hidden traits. An innate versus learned traits.
So let's see if you can classify height for
each of this categories. Is it physical or behavioral?
Is it visible or is it hidden? Or is it
innate or is it learned? Check out the boxes that apply.